A mini vehicle the size of a small suitcase is taken for a spin by its owner in China.
The fully functioning mini car is 60 centimeters in length,...
...35 centimeters in width and 40 centimeters in height.
Xu Zhiyun, a 60-year-old Shanghai resident, takes great pride in his creation.
The vehicle has nightlights and turn signals that are automatic,...
...following the direction of the steering wheel.
It also has a sound system, which can be controlled remotely.
With a top speed of just over 12 miles per hour...
...it apparently only needs four liters of petrol to run a day.
Xu spent two years making the vehicle,...
...using mostly spare parts he collected from car repair shops.